the movie opens up in the near future
where significant advancements to
humanity have been made biotechnology
company aeon offers a medical procedure
that lets people transfer time from
their own lives to someone else's body
as long as they have a DNA match this
way those who need money can sell years
of their lives making them age quickly
on the other hand the buyers get their
youth back and become immortal normally
only desperate poor people agree to
donate their time though aeon promotes
it as a choice and a donation this has
become a primary way for migrants and
Asylum Seekers to earn a living as there
are many of them in this future aeon
prioritizes Scholars artists celebrities
and even Nobel winners with time
donations they believe that if top
influencers will get more years to live
they can surely contribute for the
betterment of society next we are
introduced to the company's top manager
Max who approaches the potential donors
and personally persuades them to sell
their years today he convinces a teen
from a migrant family to solve 15 years
to improve their situation Max shares
with the teenager about how he sold five
years to afford college and emphasizes
how the money could help the family
start a business since their chances of
legal residency are low initially the
teenager refuses his 15 years is a long
long duration but with the cunning Max's
persuasion and a jaw-drop in
compensation of 7 million euros he
agrees in the next scene Max is on his
way to the company when he encounters a
group protesting against aeon's
technology due to the increasing
societal inequality Max quietly proceeds
forward and Dons a raincoat to Shield
against Throne objects inside there is a
grand program to honor the best workers
for the company and to discuss the
future plans following this aeon's
founder Sophie theison appears on the
stage and begins Distributing the awards
Max is also honored for being the best
agent and bringing in the largest
numbers of donors to the company
meanwhile Sophie announces that they
have selected 15 scientists and donated
each of them with 15 years of life to
continue their research for Human
Society the scene shifts to a facility
where those scientists are being
prepared for the process to their bad
luck a man posing as an employee enters
the scene and shoots several people dead
he then leaves a graffiti symbol on the
wall before escaping later we get to
know that the assailant belongs to the
atom group an anti-aeon organization
which is using terrorism to stop the
company from targeting poor people they
believe that they're saving Society
afterwards Sophie along with her
personal guards Kaya and noack watch a
threat video sent by Adam's leader
Lilith she promises more chaos if they
don't stop their operations anytime soon
on the other hand Max celebrates his
award with his girlfriend Elena the two
have recently rented an apartment and
wished to own it one day max assures
Elena that once he gets a promotion in
his company they will have enough money
to buy the apartment the next day the
couple visits Elena's parents and she
introduces Max to them he makes an
instant impression on the parents and
they give him their blessing later in
the evening when the couple reaches
their apartment building they are
shocked to find it in a burning State
all of their belongings have been
destroyed including their money the
following day they visit the insurance
company to claim the refund however an
agent informs them that it won't be
possible as the couple themselves are to
blame for the incident they carelessly
forgot to put out a candle before
leaving the apartment as the couple
searches for ways to pay out the loan
max shockingly discovers that Elena used
her life years as collateral for a bank
loan without telling him when he tries
to offer his years instead he's rejected
due to no compatible recipients this
confuses Max as he donated before but he
is told that his recipient recently died
and he cannot donate his years for Elena
moving on as soon as Max and Elena leave
the insurance company the police arrest
the latter to stop her from leaving the
country desperate Max pledges to find an
alternative way to pay the bank he talks
to Sophie about his situation and she
agrees to assist however she soon starts
ignoring his calls implying that she is
not going to help now with no options
left the bank is going to take 40 years
off of Elena's life which will make her
old frustrated and worried Max goes to
the clinic see Elena before the
procedure to his dismay he is denied and
the staff also tell him that he must
wait until the procedure is done losing
his composure Max tries to reach Elena
by rushing into the other rooms but Kaya
and her team stop him meanwhile Elena
gets prepared for the procedure hearing
a lawyer read the contract pushes her
over the edge she struggles against the
doctors but they inject her making her
fall asleep her years are transferred to
another person in a different room whose
identity is kept Anonymous t-swift after
the procedure Max takes Elena home she's
visibly changed now looking much older
Max's dream of having kids with her is
also gone and their relationship becomes
strained with Elena distancing herself
from him despite his attempts to comfort
her she remains distant and so one day
max is called to the company and offered
a promotion with a salary increase which
he now finds pointless angry he tries to
talk to Sophie but Kaya intervenes
Sophie also ignores him and leaves in
her car surprisingly as she is heading
out Max notices that she's looking much
younger back home Max tries to show
affection to Elena assuring her that he
still loves her and will do anything to
give back her 40 years of life however
she interprets it as pity and asks to be
left alone later Elena experiences
abdominal pain and bleeding leading her
to the hospital Max is by her side and
he discovers that she had been pregnant
before the procedure however due to her
older body's limitations the baby is now
gone aggrieved and in pain Elena decides
to move in with her parents tired of
their awkward life her parents are
shocked to see her as she looks older
than her mother they blame Max for
everything highlighting his role in the
system's Creation in response the latter
promises to do his best to reverse the
procedure before driving away from there
desperate and alone max sits in the park
and looks at the people around at the
same time he notices a little girl
selling narcotics and smoking cigarettes
he is sure that the girl did the age
reducing procedure and transformed
herself into a little girl to carry out
the illegal business Max confronts the
girl and demands information about her
procedure source as aeon doesn't allow
kids to go through the process through
her he gets the contact of an
underground group in Lithuania that
performs age transplant surgeries at a
low price without wasting any time Max
contacts the underground group using a
burner phone and is instructed to
acquire fake passports in a shady
neighborhood he learns that he needs to
find the recipient who now holds Elena's
ears before leaving for Lithuania
afterward Max hides in a hotel and
devises a plan to kidnap Sophie he
suspects that she was the one who took
away his girlfriend's years he follows
her wherever she goes over the next few
days and shadows Sophie until he finds a
moment in his Cemetery where she's alone
without guards pretending to be a member
of the atom group he approaches her with
his face covered Sophia house and tries
to escape but Max catches up and
incapacitates her with a laser he then
paints an A on a nearby grave to make
the kidnap seem like the work of the
group or perhaps aeon and he just
self-reported later Max picks up Elena
from her workplace urging her to trust
him they then head to an abandoned
building where he's keeping Sophie tied
up Elena is skeptical about the
situation and a disagreement ensues but
Max convinces her that this is their
chance to rebuild their lives and have a
family following this they reach the
harbor and managed to board a ship
without much trouble to make their way
to Lithuania meanwhile Kaya and Nowak
investigate the situation of the
cemetery using security camera footage
to trace the kidnapper soon they
realized that it was done by someone
from their company and find that Max has
been using fake accounts for purchases
they also notice Max's presence captured
on a security camera at a harbor and now
are on the hunt for him as Max leaves on
a ship with Elena and Sophie Kaya and
noack organize a new operation involving
the police to catch them at the harbor
Max takes care of Sophie checking on her
and providing food and drinks she's
concealed inside a box pretending to be
Cargo in the evening the couple watches
a happy family and dreams of having
their own children someday suddenly a
child mentions some strange lights at
the shore Max and Elena investigate only
to learn that aeon has contacted the
Lithuanian police and they are waiting
for them thinking on his feet Max
decides to use an innocent family to
their advantage when the police inspect
cars leaving the ship Max using his gun
coerces the family's father to drive his
van and pose as a delivery worker Max
guides the driver via a Bluetooth earbud
until the officer allows him to leave
although they managed to escape Elena
becomes angry as Max endangered the
lives of innocent people nonetheless
they borrow the family's van and leave a
few hours later they stop in the middle
of the road for Sophie who reveals that
she isn't actually Sophie but her
daughter Marie Max does her story and
searches online he finds out that Sophie
only had one daughter who died long ago
in response Marie explains that her
mother intentionally kept a low profile
to avoid media attention she only wanted
her child to live a normal life however
Max remains skeptical and Elena begins
to have doubts too afterward they find
an abandoned hotel to spend the night
Marie assures them that she's not Sophie
as she too opposes her mother's
unethical work however as a desperate
Max asserts that even if she's telling
the truth her DNA should be a match for
Elena hence he wants to proceed with the
plan this idea horrifies Elena and she
leaves the room later as Marie takes a
shower Elena notices that she doesn't
contain any scars on her body this means
that she has never been through the
procedure Elena talks to Max about it
but he assures her that after the skin
becomes young the scars heal magically
meanwhile Noah conforms Kaya about the
couple's location and they prepare to
head there however before they can do so
the armed Adam group led by Lilith find
Elena and Max Lilith then confirms that
Maria is indeed Sophie's daughter in the
next scene the atom group takes the trio
to an abandoned building where Lilith
reveals Sophie's master plan she
mentions that Sophie intended to use
Elena as an age donor for herself but
Max and Elena fell in love and married
she also orchestrated their apartment
fire and had Max's potential match
killed to prevent him from donating his
years enraged Max accuses Lilith of
being a murderer but she responds by
offering Elena a gun with one bullet
giving her the choice to kill Marie or
herself overwhelmed Elena drops the gun
and starts crying just that Max's burner
phone receives the location of an
illegal Clinic valid for six hours to
make the appointment the couple must
assist Lilith in killing Sophie after a
while Kaya and her team surround the
building and Max emerges pretending that
Adam isn't with them he warns them that
only Sophie will be allowed inside and
if anyone disobeys him Elena will shoot
Marie dead at this moment a rejuvenated
Sophie steps forward and agrees to the
terms as she's about to enter Kaya
questions how Max knew Sophie would be
there and realizes that it's a trap from
inside the building the atom group
starts shooting at Sophie's team and a
gunfight ensues between the groups lots
of people are killed on the spot
including noack and Lilith amidst the
chaos Max retreats to the hotel and
takes Elena and Marie to the garage for
an escape while attempting to start the
car Marie reveals that she has a gun and
tries to shoot Elena but fortunately
there are no bullets in it this act of
betrayal deeply hurts Elena as she had
just spared her life sometime before in
response she hits Marie in the head
making her fall on
and the trio flees in the car later Max
admits he's hesitant to harm Marie to
avoid becoming like Lilith however Elena
has had enough and forces max out of the
car threatening to harm herself she then
proceeds to the illegal Clinic where
Maria is reluctantly subjected to the
procedure sometime later Maria is
discovered by a truck driver who returns
her to the city she then reunites with
her young mother Sophie who survived the
gunfight due to wearing a bulletproof
vest but what if they shot her in the
face in the coming days Marie begins to
age rapidly and the only one who can
donate her years is her mother however
Sophie turns selfish and refuses to
donate to her own daughter promising to
find help soon in the last scene Max
encounters Elena at the beach she
appears youthful and Pregnant
accompanied by a new husband Max accepts
his new life as a rebel with the atom
group dedicated to taking down Sophie's
unethical practices and saving the
Innocence from losing their years of
life subscribe for more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you you
for watching